imagine two people who need to share a
secret for example a numeric key the
simplest solution is to make copies of
that secret and share it but what
happens when no single person should
have full access to a secret for example
missile launch codes or passwords for
large money transfers which may require
multiple people to confirm in these
situations we require some minimum
number of people to come to a consensus
before applying a key the simplest
approach to this problem is to split up
the secret into pieces or shares and
keep them secret from one another then
combine the secret shares whenever they
need to apply a secret key the problem
with this method is each half of the key
gives away partial information about the
secret to each person for example with
an eight digit secret if one person
knows the first four digits then they
only need to guess through 10,000
possible combinations to find the key or
ask someone with no information would
need to guess from 100 million possible
combinations recall that the definition
of perfect secrecy from an information
theory perspective requires that every
possible key looked equally likely this
means that someone with one share is no
more likely to guess the key than
someone who doesn't have a share in
order to prevent the information leaked
we need to introduce some randomness for
example if the secret was an image we
could protect that secret by adding a
random image to it resulting in an
unrecognizable scrambled image then one
person could take the random image the
other could take the scrambled image and
when they need to recover the original
image they just subtract the random
image from the scrambled image in this
case the secret shares on their own
contain no information about the
original image but together they recover
it perfectly that's the idea with images
but we can do the same thing numerically
take the secret and add a random number
to it using modular arithmetic which
means we add the numbers digit by digit
and if the result is 10 or above we only
show the remainder
and no carry operations occur so 11
becomes a 1 this allows the secret to be
broken into random looking pieces which
we can give to each person without
either of them seeing the original
secret one person gets the random number
the other gets the result of adding the
secret to a random number or a random
secret there is no way to extract the
original number from what is available
to either person for example if we take
5 plus 6 equals 1 and I give you only
the 1 you have no information about what
two numbers led to it so to determine
the secret the 2 participants must come
together and subtract their numbers to
reverse the random process and recover
the secret this simple procedure is
known as a one-time pad and was proven
to be perfectly secret by Claude Shannon
but we aren't quite done yet because
when we try this approach with many
participants we run into another problem
using this method all shares are
required to generate the secret if one
of the eight people go missing loses a
key or decides not to cooperate the
secret is then lost to everyone
practically speaking this is not
acceptable for many applications since
it has one point of failure in these
cases what we need is a system where
only some of the eight people need to
come together to recover the secret for
example we might require that at least
five out of eight people come together
this problem was solved in 1979 by Adi
Shamir who published a paper which
tackled the problem of sharing a secret
amongst multiple parties he expanded the
idea geometrically by imagining the
secret as a point in space and the
shares as points along a secret random
curve for example imagine we have a
secret number shared amongst three
people and we want to make sure that at
least two are needed to recover the
secret his key insight was to think
about this number as a secret point in
2d space where the secret is a point on
the y axis where the y coordinate of
that point is a number we want to keep
secret then we introduce randomness by
selecting a random point in the 2d plane
and out of those two points we form
secret line this trick effectively
expands the secret from a point to a
line creating lots of redundancy out of
which we can create as many shares as we
wish
where each share is a point anywhere on
the secret line now all we need is any
two shares to recover the secret line
once we know the line we can see where
it intersects the y-axis and finally the
y coordinate of that point is our secret
with this method we can share a secret
with as many people as we need which we
call N and make sure that any two people
can recover the secret known as a 2n
scheme but if we want to increase the
minimum number of people needed to
recover a secret then we need to simply
turn our line into a curve for example
the simplest curve is a parabola which
can be defined by three points to create
a secret parabola we start with the
secret point as before and then we
generate two random points to define the
secret curve then we can generate as
many secret shares as we'd like along
the curve recall that the equation for a
parabola takes the following form and
since this equation has three parameters
a B and C we need any three points along
the curve to solve for a given parameter
so ignoring everything and given any
three shares we can fully recover the
curve and then we can solve for C which
is the secret point or y-intercept to
get back the secret number this is known
as a 3n scheme since we need at least
three shares to recover the secret if
instead we want a minimum of four shares
to define the secret then we'll need to
move up to a cubic curve which will
require four points to define and
recover the secret in the same way using
any four points this is known as a
forensic eeeem finally we can generalize
the scheme to work with any subset size
K we desire by using a curve which is
defined by K points then we can generate
as many shares as we'd want defined by n
leading to a KN sharing scheme where K
is the minimum
of shares to unlock a secret and that's
it in practice these same ideas apply
when we work with integer coordinates
and modulo operations instead of real
numbers which makes the scheme practical
to implement and because we have
efficient algorithms for computing these
curves it makes this method a practical
key management solution it is also
interesting to notice that the methods
we are using here rely on a well-known
algorithm called a reed-solomon code
reed-solomon codes were originally
developed for erasure and error
correction where a transmission or
message is broken up into n pieces and
some of these pieces can be lost during
transmission due to erasers which is the
same as a loss share the reed-solomon
code enables data reconstruction on the
receiving end as long as K of the pieces
arrive plus there are many other
connections as well such as secure
multi-party computation and data privacy
which are widely used to this day all
thanks to an elegant solution for how to
share our secrets
[Music]
you
you
[Music]